lo que quiero hacer en este vídeo es
revisar algunas técnicas para hacer
sumas mentales si yo me encuentro algo
como 355 480 que tenemos un papel a la
mano podemos escribir esas cantidades y
hacer la suma de manera tradicional pero
quizás ustedes quieran hacer estos
cálculos mentalmente como lo harían
podemos sumar o restar algo de manera
que algunos de estos números quede de
manera más simple por ejemplo aquí tengo
480 que tendría que hacerle a este 480
para que se volviera a 500 480 acá si es
pues puedo sumarle 20 a 480 pero no
puedo sumarlo solamente estos 20 acá
tengo que restar los de aquí qué pasa si
le restó a 355 20 y eso es 20 los agregó
al 480 esto va a ser lo mismo que
quitamos 20 de aquí va a ser 335 y le
agregamos 20 a esto 480 más 20 es 500
y la razón por la que quité 20 de aquí y
se los agregué acá es para convertir
estos 480 en 500 que es una cantidad más
fácil de sumar y esto lo puedo hacer en
mi mente si le agrego 20 a 480 le quito
20 a 355 y me queda 335 y ahora este
problema es mucho más fácil de calcular
335 más 500 va a ser 835 300 más 500 va
a ser 800 y nos queda 35 y para ser un
poco más claro lo que hicimos
recuerden que tomamos 20 de aquí y se
los agregamos acá este 355 lo
descomponemos en 335 más 20 y la razón
por la que elegí 20 es porque se los
quiero sumar a estos 480 pero aquí lo
estamos haciendo paso a paso más 480
y ahora puedo cambiar el orden de esta
suma
así que esto es igual a 335 más 20 más
y este 20 en lugar de sumarlo al 335 lo
voy a sumar al 480 sumamos estos dos
términos primero
y ahora nos vamos a quedar con 335 más
480 más 20 este es el objetivo de lo que
hicimos poder llegar a los 500
ahora podemos sumar ambos 835 esta es
una forma un poco más extensa de lo que
hicimos aquí le quitamos 20 al 355 para
poder hacer que el 480 llegara al 500
hagamos algunos ejemplos más recuerden
que aquí la clave es ver de qué manera
puedo sumar o restar algo para que
algunos de estos números me quede más
sencillo aquí tenemos 18 704 hay dos
formas en que podríamos calcular esto 1
es tomar este 704 para hacerlo igual a
700 podemos decir que esto es igual a 18
más 700 4 o también lo puedo escribir
como 4 más 700 y después puedo cambiar
el orden en el que voy a hacer la suma
esto es lo mismo que 18
más 700
ahora asumo primero el 18 más el 4 18 4
es 22 más 700
y eso es bastante sencillo de calcular
y bueno todos estos son iguales le pongo
el igual a todos
22 más setecientos puedo hacer la suma
en mi mente esto es igual a 722 y bueno
sé que a lo mejor ustedes están
preguntando oye se supone que estos son
cálculos mentales pero tú aquí estás
escribiendo todas las operaciones y no
puedo escribir todas estas operaciones
en mi mente fue la razón por la que hago
esto de esta manera es para que les
quede bien claro a ustedes que se está
haciendo paso a paso
pero ustedes en su mente lo pueden hacer
mucho más rápido
pueden tomar este 704 y ahorita tengo
los ojos cerrados para hacer el cálculo
mental tengo en mi mente el 704 y le
agrego 4 al 18 y le quitó ese 4 al 704
si le agrego 4 a 18 va a ser 18 19 20 21
y 22 y si le quito 4 al 704 me va a
quedar 700
22 700 y 722
y hay otra forma de resolver esto en
lugar de quitar el 4 al 704 podemos
agregarle algo de manera que nos queden
710 aunque bueno para mí no es tan ideal
esto pero se puede hacer si le agregamos
6 704 nos quedará 710 así que a este 18
le quito 6 para sumarlo a éste 704 puedo
escribirlo así 18 es igual a 12 + 6 +
qué es lo mismo que 12 más 6
mas 704
y ahora asumo primero estos dos tenemos
12 + 710
ahora vemos que nos queda 722 aunque en
mi opinión este método no es tan
intuitivo como el primero que vimos el
tratar de tener al 704 como 700
restándole 4 y después sumando lo al 18
hagamos un ejemplo más 275 más 595 bueno
mi primer impulso es de tratar de volver
a éste 595 en 600 si le agrego 5 a 595
me voy a quedar con 600 pero como no
puedo agregar solamente 5 acá tengo que
quitarlos de aquí así que este 275 le
voy a restar 5 y nos quedará 270 esto se
vuelve 270 más 600 va a ser igual a 870
esto es mucho más sencillo de calcular
en mi mente 200 más 600 son 800 siete
décimas más cero décimas son siete
décimas
y no tengo ninguna unidad 0 870 otra
forma de resolver esto es tratar de
dejar este 275 como 280 como 300 podemos
decir que esto va a ser 300 y para tener
esta cantidad le sume 25 y si agregué 25
acá tengo que quitar 25 aquí le restamos
25 voy a tener 300 más 595 menos 25 van
a ser 570 y eso también es fácil de
calcular 300 más 570 va a ser igual a
870 y hay otras formas de calcularlo
incluyendo la forma tradicional de
escribir las cantidades en papel y hacer
la suma directamente en el papel pero yo
espero que esto les haya dado algunas
herramientas para poder hacer estos
cálculos mentales más fácilmente